for government is transforming 27 acres
of land in Ashford and Kent into a new
border control center and lorry park for
when the brakes of transition period
comes to an end work has started at the
site which could help deal with
disruption at the borders after the 31st
of December but the local MP and former
Deputy Prime Minister Damien green told
us he objects to the plans if there's
disruption
even the government wants to have the
extra insurance of maybe Loring Park I
think this is exactly the wrong place to
put it it's far too close to a
residential area in the long term
governments to user incoming traffic to
check occasional lorries for customs
purposes and I think that's perfectly
acceptable it's the it's the Act banned
big lorry part that I think is
unacceptable
well skies know Phillips is at the site
in Ashford an old too many local people
there support what he's saying what are
some people who have come to decide to
show their support as a man who's lived
in a local area since the 1960s he
reckons this is a perfect place for this
zone for this thing which has been
described as a lorry park and I'll just
show you where we're standing so you can
get a sense of where we are just imagine
10,000 lorries all on this field all on
this site as a forum at next January
2021 obviously this is all in aid of the
government's 700 million plan to upgrade
the border system which will need to be
in place by the end of the brexit
transition period but 27 acres of land
which will be turned into a brexit
clearance center processing law is
coming into the into the UK form
European countries but as I said that
man reckons it's a great it's a great
idea he is very much in support of it
there are local people who object to the
plans they say they've woken up this
morning they've turn on their TVs
they've gone onto the internet and have
looked at their local news site owners
and and this is a first day hearing of
these plans so there are some people who
are concerned about the fact that there
are no consultations that you know that
have taken place the former diplomat
Peter Ricketts has described the plans
as pointless and then in green term
concerns I think has been echo
nearby there are people still coming
into the area and just sort of I think
just soaking up the idea of this quiet
piece of land being turned into a huge
Louis Park as I said up to 10,000 Louis
could be and could be on this land and
in a matter of months the local deputy
leader of the council Peter Barlow he's
sits on a Sports Council he's he's
welcome to plans at saying if things go
according to plan the benefits will be
huge to local people and also the
economy as well and I think there were
talks of this new brexit Clarence Center
which will be on this very hard where
we're standing it's quite extraordinary
- taken actually Jane it will create a
lot of jobs and will be a huge benefit
to the local area